HAASS: Well, we will get started.
Welcome to the Council on Foreign Relations.
I'm Richard Haass.
And this is part of a series of events which
are high on my list of favorite events because
it is a book launch and that suggests a book
has been written, which in fact it has, in
this case by Josh Kurlantzick who is a senior
fellow here at the Council on Foreign Relations
and is our expert on all things Southeast
Asia, although in this case he has taken not
a geographic approach, but a functional approach
and is tackling the question of what he describes
as state capitalism.
Let me make sure that is shown.
The subtitle is-OK, this is a New York City
driving exam eye test and I just flunked-"How
the Return of Statism is Transforming the
World."
Congratulations.
KURLANTZICK: Thank you.
Thank you.
HAASS: So Josh and I are going to talk for
a few minutes about the book and then we're
going to open it up to you for your questions,
your comments, above all your applause and
congratulations because all authors deserve
it and need it.
So, Josh, let's start out at the beginning,
at the basic just so we understand exactly
what it is we're talking about and ultimately
reading about, which is, what is state capitalism?
KURLANTZICK: OK.
Well, thanks to everyone for coming.
In the book I look at the growth of what I
call modern state capitalism over the last
15 years, a number of prominent, mostly developing
countries where the state has exerted greater
control of the economy.
And in the book, to differentiate it from
states where the state accounts for a significant
percentage of GDP through welfare spending
or entitlements, et cetera, I just look at
states in which the state has control or de
facto control of one-third of the largest
companies in that country.
And that gives these states like China, like
Venezuela, a number of these are in the news
now, not always for such good reasons, like
Thailand, like Malaysia, Russia, give the
state much more direct leverage over the corporate
sector than they would have if the state accounted
for GDP through welfare spending, through
defense, et cetera.
HAASS: So this is-we would expect this in
places, say, like a Saudi Arabia where you
have a cash crop, a large, extractive industry,
but you're writing much more broadly, correct?
KURLANTZICK: Right.
I mean, there is quite a wide range in the
book.
There are-there's two spectrums.
There is the spectrum of state capitalists
who are highly inefficient, like Russia in
which the state has captured a significant
portion of the corporate sector and has resulted
in an extremely predatory type of pseudo-capitalism,
all the way to ones which are somewhat more
efficient, on the end of Singapore, Vietnam,
Thailand, and even China which, despite significant
problems, is a much more efficient economy.
And the other spectrum is autocratic to democratic,
and there are some overlaps there, but not
only natural resources countries.
HAASS: And are we seeing more state capitalism
recently or now?
If so, why?
And does state capitalism, how would I put
it, does it wax and wane?
If you were going to take a long, historical
take on it, have there been previous periods
when state capitalism was on rise, and have
there been periods when state capitalism was
on the fall?
KURLANTZICK: Well, certainly we have seen
different periods.
But this is a period that has grown since
the late '90s, early 2000s.
So there was another period after the Second
World War in which there was an era of import
substitution, statist economics, et cetera.
What we're seeing now is a number of trends
that have come together.
One, you have a number of countries, Turkey-Turkey's
not state capitalist-but Turkey, Thailand,
Russia, Venezuela, Malaysia, others, leaders
who are kind of, like, elected autocrats.
They were elected in elections that run on
the spectrum of freedom, but they had elections.
But they also don't really subscribe to the
constitutional bases of democracy, so they're
elected autocrats.
For them, state capitalism is also a means
of perpetuating their power.
Second, you had in the Asian financial crisis
and post-2008 financial crisis significant
weakening of the allure of the Western economic
model or of the free market economic model.
Third, you have the example of China as a
kind of counterweight.
And then fourth, particularly after 2008,
a lot of developing countries, I think, also
saw that doing new bank regulations in Europe
particularly and other reasons, many of their
industries were starved of possible infusions
of capital, and they were looking for other
places for capital.
So there have been previous eras, but this
is an era dating back to the late '90s, early
2000s.
HAASS: OK.
You mentioned what I thought you were going
to say, which is 2008 clearly hurt the alternative
model, I guess you'd call it more market capitalism
as opposed to-what is the opposite of state
capitalism?
What do you call it?
KURLANTZICK: Yeah, free market capitalism.
HAASS: OK.
KURLANTZICK: And obviously there's some spectrum,
but if you take, say, Hong Kong on one end
and North Korea on the other or something
like that.
HAASS: Yeah, that kind of puts you beyond
the end zones.
Does this suggest-I guess maybe I'll ask the
question this way.
Are we at something of an apogee-i.e., if
China were to have some real problems, and
it's obviously slowing considerably, does
this potentially taint the appeal of state
capitalism, what we're going to see then down
the road, Brazil's got problems, China's got
problems, and so forth, that we think maybe
state capitalism has peaked and in a few years,
you know, you wouldn't be writing this book?
KURLANTZICK: Well, I think that we are seeing
significant problems in all the different-first
of all, I don't think the free market model
is the alternative.
This was the alternative, so now we're in
two different potential alternatives.
But China has problems, Brazil has problems,
but still China's growth rate over the last
35 years is staggering.
And at the same time, a lot of the problems
of free market capitalism we've seen reflected
along with other trends, but the growth of
populist parties in the West, so both of the
models, I think, have substantial problems.
But the longer that China in particular continues
to grow substantially, the more attractive
it remains as a model for other countries.
It doesn't necessarily have to grow at the
rates as it did before, but just continuing
to grow.
I can talk about, if people have questions,
there are significant flaws, there's NPLs
piling up.
But the longer that China continues to grow
and also become more assertive in promoting
its model, it does-
HAASS: NPLs mean non-performing loans?
KURLANTZICK: Non-performing loans.
HAASS: OK.
KURLANTZICK: China's state banks and state
companies still need substantial reform.
HAASS: SOEs.
We can kind of make this like a NATO meeting
and just use acronyms-(laughter)-and all that.
Let's talk about Brazil for a second because
it's much in the news.
You're about to have the entire world focus
on it.
What are we, roughly, six weeks or so, give
or take, away from the Olympics?
You've got the impeachment trial of the president.
You've got corruption on steroids, literally
and figuratively I guess I'd say, not bad-(laughter)
-in Brazil.
What does that tell us about state capitalism?
Or to ask a question in a more leading way,
is it just about inevitable that state capitalism
leads to corruption?
Do the two almost inextricably go hand-in-hand?
KURLANTZICK: Probably in the long term, although
there are examples, again on a spectrum there
is not a high level of corruption in Singapore
and Norway, which I also look at in the book.
I think that Brazil is an interesting example
because, one, it shows in the long term that
there are significant problems with state
capitalism in terms of graft.
They can be avoided, but it's very difficult.
But on the other hand, even though there has
been significant graft, there hasn't been
significant pressure in Brazil for a dramatic
shift in economic policy.
There have been pressures for cleaning up
graft and total disgust, but you're not actually
seeing a dramatic swing to pressure for complete
disavowal of the Lula/Dilma policies.
So you have democratically elected politicians
who want to respond to public demand for a
degree of state intervention, but they're
sort of stuck in a trap there.
HAASS: So let me circle back in a different
way.
If you were going to choose the places, either
current or historical, where state capitalism
really looked pretty good in terms of overall
growth, both in the collective sense as well
as per capita, rising living standards and
all that, like, what would be your-what's
on the short list of places where state capitalism
seems to have worked?
KURLANTZICK: It has worked pretty well in
Singapore, although I know there are huge
human rights problems.
It has worked with the state providing initial
capital in Rwanda.
It has worked quite effectively in Norway
where they combine state companies with a
high degree of free market-type governance.
It has worked somewhat effectively in Thailand
and Malaysia.
It has worked somewhat effectively in Indonesia.
And to be fair, it has worked somewhat effectively
for a long period of time in China.
HAASS: Now, most of those, but not all of
those tend to be more towards the developing
side of the spectrum than mature.
So is there an argument that state capitalism
might lend itself to developing economies,
but at a point at which, say, GDP per capita
is above X, 10,000, I don't know what the
number is, that it no longer makes so much
sense?
KURLANTZICK: Yeah, I think that that's an
argument, although we're going to see it play
out in China, which is the biggest example.
In Singapore, when Singapore basically was
divorced from Malaysia, the government needed
some way to launch a range of industries.
They were having troubling, they had very
shallow capital markets, no one really wanted
to invest in Singapore.
The government used state resources to both
attract investment and to provide some seed
capital as kind of an angel investor in a
few industries.
Now the government has stepped back somewhat,
and that's kind of the model that a lot of
other countries are looking for, so that's,
like, the ideal model.
HAASS: Would Japan have been a country that
at one point you would have described as state
capitalist and has, to some extent, evolved
so it's less so?
KURLANTZICK: Yeah, probably you would.
I mean, the government links are a little
bit less clear because of the ways that the
government, the ministries, and the major
companies interact or are a little bit less
clear, but yes.
HAASS: And what are the biggest present or
historic failures of state capitalism?
Where has it clearly done little or no good
for the society?
KURLANTZICK: Well, the most obvious example
and the one that's most worrisome because
you have a combination of predatory capitalism
with one of the world's major military powers
is Russia.
You have a total failure of using the state
to support innovation.
You have predation that has crowded out entrepreneurship.
You have Russian elites who have left, and
you have a very angry nationalism.
HAASS: What about Venezuela?
KURLANTZICK: Venezuela I would say would be
number two, just Venezuela.
Although the collapse of the Venezuelan economy
is problematic, it's not the same as a potential
collapse of the Russian economy, plus Venezuela
doesn't have nuclear weapons, doesn't have
a Pacific fleet, et cetera.
HAASS: I asked you before about corruption
and whether there was something about state
capitalism that more or less inevitably increased
the odds that corruption would become a significant
problem.
What about democracy and human rights?
To what extent does state capitalism almost
ensure that, how would I put it, that the
political evolution or development of society
lags?
KURLANTZICK: I'm not sure that the evidence
is so clear on that as it is on corruption.
If you take an overlap of countries and the
degree of state intervention in the economy
with Freedom House's Freedom in the World
scale, there is not a direct overlap.
There are countries that have historically
been state capitalist that are democracies.
There are countries today, even Brazil, which
is, for all of its problems, a relatively
vibrant democracy.
The problems that are coming out in Brazil
you wouldn't see exposed in Russia because
there are no institutions to expose them.
So I think it's possible that in the hands
of someone like Thaksin Shinawatra, Prime
Minister Najib of Malaysia, and others, state
enterprises can be deployed to limit political
opposition, but it's not an exact match, it's
not necessarily so.
HAASS: When economies that are, quote, unquote,
"state capitalists" in their DNA or nature,
when they run into problems, is the tendency
to become more state or more capitalist?
KURLANTZICK: I think that that depends largely
on the government and it depends largely on
the quality of government.
In Singapore, I think the tendency has become
more capitalist, and I think that that is
also true in some other countries.
In China, despite promises by the current
government, the tendency, because they have
a much greater desire for control, the tendency
is to become more state.
HAASS: That certainly does these days.
You're a specialist on Southeast Asia, so
let me combine the two.
What is your part of the world, what's the
evidence there?
You mentioned before Indonesia, Thailand,
Vietnam now increasingly as probably entering
the state capitalist space, so what are we
seeing there?
KURLANTZICK: What we're seeing in Southeast
Asia, as a region that once was considered
both an economic model and also, in many ways,
a model of democratization, has, with a few
notable exceptions, significantly regressed.
And you have in Thailand a military junta
which is increasingly meddling in a lot of
realms of the economy.
You have in Malaysia real regression democratically
and a government that's also increasingly
using state enterprises a kind of political
vote banks.
Singapore is an exception, but you now have
in the Philippines a new president, and it's
unclear what's going to happen, but he has
vowed to himself kill alleged criminals.
It's not a great statement for the rule of
law.
And he also comes from a background that is
very much inclined towards using state enterprises
as a political tool.
So you've had a meshing there of some pretty
worrying trends.
HAASS: Are there certain prerequisites that
if they're there increases the odds a country
will go down this path and if they're absent
it won't?
For example, India is not particularly going
down this path, so what is it about India
explains the fact that it has not opted for
state capitalism?
KURLANTZICK: Well, India did opt for a highly
socialist economy in the past.
HAASS: Yeah, correct.
KURLANTZICK: And so I think one thing that
is clear is if you try this and it fails people
will go in a different direction.
And so India and Indonesia have opted for
less than, say, Malaysia because it had such
significant failures with it.
In addition, I think in a place like India
or some other countries that have opted away
from it, the influence of democratic civil
society and democratic civil society that
has been seen, an interplay between state
capitalism and authoritarian rule in the past,
so that's one reason why on India.
But you know, I think there's on one factor.
But for those who see going down this road
the last 10 or 15 years, I think the model
of China's success, and China's also become
increasingly interested in promoting and success
through a range of kind of soft power tools
as well.
HAASS: But if a lot of the pessimists then-I'm
going to open things up in a second-if a lot
of the pessimists turn out to be right about
China, that its real rate of growth now is
way, way low, and even that rate of growth
is largely because of public infusions of
money rather than real economic growth, then
it suggests to me not only might China be
in some difficulty, but the model that China's
been so responsible for might be in difficulty.
KURLANTZICK: No, I think that's accurate.
I mean, I think we have to see that play out.
I don't disagree with that.
I think that we'll have to see how that plays
out.
I mean, there has been a high degree of pessimism.
I think some of that is warranted.
But it's been still a quite impressive model
for some time.
HAASS: And lastly, if I were to add up, I'd
have to think about it, but state capitalist
economies in the world and not, it would seem
to me that state capitalism or economies that
are so defined or described would still be
less than half of the world's economies.
Simply the U.S. and Europe alone would pretty
much get you to the 50 percent line and a
few others would get you above it.
Is that fair?
KURLANTZICK: Yeah, that's fair, it depends
on the growth rate of China.
HAASS: OK, it all comes down to China.
OK.
Why don't I stop?
Why don't we open it up to you, our members
and guests, to ask your questions?
What we will do, we have this new invention
called the microphone, so when it comes around
if you want to raise your hand we'll give
it to you, if you'd give us your name and
your affiliation and ask a question of Josh
Kurlantzick.
That would be great.
I should also-I've been remiss.
I've not mentioned that this book is published
by Oxford University Press.
And even more important, it is for sale approximately
20 yards in that direction, by that happy
gentleman sitting there.
But he was feeling a little bit lonely and
wishes he had more attention and more business.
This is our version of state capitalism.
(Laughter.)
We are encouraging you to participate in the
local economy here.
OK.
So any hands up?
I see two gentlemen in beige suits, so we'll
get the one closer to me and then the one
farther away from me.
I don't have my glasses on, I can't take it
that far.
Q: Niso Abuaf, Pace University.
This morning on CNBC, none other than Larry
Fink of Blackrock suggested that the solution
to the current malaise of very low or negative
interest rates is private-public partnership.
That sounds like state capitalism to me in
the developed world.
I was wondering if you have any thoughts about
that.
KURLANTZICK: Sure.
I mean, I'm not an expert on what's going
to solve negative interest rates, but there
are elements of that.
If you go back to Singapore, in the early
days there was a very statist model, and then
you have now a situation in which there are
some state-public partnerships in a number
of industries the Singapore government believes
are crucial to the future, state-public partnerships
in building infrastructure, which is certainly
something that we need here.
But the state also forces both state companies
and private sector companies to compete quite
intensively, something that you don't get
in a place like Russia and that you get only
somewhat in China.
HAASS: Yeah, and depending upon the rules
or constitution, say, of a national or regional
infrastructure bank, they might or might not
qualify.
And if you have public-private, almost the
percentage of public and the percentage of
private, both in funding and in who makes
the decisions, so it could also actually be
the opposite.
To you, Craig?
Q: Yeah.
Thanks, Richard.
Craig Charney of Charney Research.
You know, I remember that when Schumpeter
was writing in the 1940s, the thought was
that the increasing role of state capitalism
would also be a redistributionist and egalitarian
force in Western societies.
I'm curious what your thought about the beneficiaries
of state capitalism today is.
I'm struck by the rollcall of countries that
you mentioned, which sound to me to be those
which have authoritarian populism as their
primary mode of governance.
So would your thought be that state capitalism
is essentially a way that elites are reinforcing
their privileges, or what?
KURLANTZICK: I think that the role is varied.
There are countries that are authoritarian
and some that are hybrid and some that are
truly democratic, like Brazil and Indonesia.
They're not ideal democracies.
In the worst of them, like Russia, the state
is using state capitalism to reward a small
group of elites.
In those that are more egalitarian, the state
is not only using state capitalism to reward
a small number of elites, but it is trying
to address inequality in some ways.
Like, for example, in Singapore and when Thaksin
Shinawatra became prime minister in Thailand,
for whatever his failings, his use of the
economy was indeed designed in part to reduce
inequality, also because that was politically
effective for him.
So I think there's a wide range.
I don't think it's only being used to reward
predatory elites.
HAASS: Someone from this side of the room.
Now, we're-yes, you have your hand up?
Yes, ma'am.
KURLANTZICK: Hi, Margaret.
Q: Hi, Joshua.
Congratulations.
I haven't read your book, but I look forward
to it.
But I-
HAASS: Margaret, you have to introduce yourself.
Q: I'm Margaret Scott, I'm a journalist, and
I've known Joshua for a long time.
I'm interested in what drew you to this subject.
Your last book was a very interesting look
at the challenges and the fragility of democratization.
This book is about the state and that state
capitalism is transforming the world.
What drew you to take a look at that?
And I'm just wondering because as a lay journalist
that doesn't know much of anything, I see
the nation state as under threat in the world
today or challenged and capitalism challenged,
too.
So I'm just interested in what drew you to
this idea of state capitalism becoming so
much stronger.
KURLANTZICK: Well, I think that this was,
in a way, kind of a pseudo-sequel to my previous
book that you mentioned, which it was about
the regression of or at least the stagnation
of democracy in a number of developing countries.
And it's possibly a hope I'll have a trilogy
because I'm interested in the combination
and not just the regression of democracy or
the failure of democratic institutions, but
the ability to take advantage of them by authoritarians
and authoritarian populists.
So that might be coming next.
But it basically stems from the previous one.
I was interested in how in a number of these
countries, particularly in Southeast Asia,
but others, state capitalism was both a predecessor
to the rise of these elected autocrats and
then often a tool that they were using to
reinforce their rule.
But it wasn't always one or the other.
And there was also these exceptions, like
in India where you have the Licence Raj, you
had quite a long period of socialism, you
had emergency rule, and yet they were able
to escape both of those.
So it sort of came from-in the democracy book,
I looked at India as a counter example where
democracy had continued to thrive compared
to a lot of other countries.
So the democratic regression sort of led into
this, and I wanted to look at the economic
side and the way that it played in.
HAASS: Just so I understand, by the way, you've
got state capitalism, you've got market, you
know, economies, and you have some, you know,
varying degrees of hybrids.
Is there something else, other than these
two poles and hybrids, is there something
else out there?
KURLANTZICK: Not that I know of.
HAASS: OK.
OK.
KURLANTZICK: I think that the hybrid can vary,
like a French hybrid, a Nordic hybrid.
HAASS: Yeah.
That's a-(pronounces with an accent)-"hybrid."
(Laughter.)
Steven?
Q: Looking at-
HAASS: You have a microphone right there.
Q: Thank you.
Looking at what we're calling state capitalism
or the hand of the state in an economy where
markets exist, there's a difference.
If you look at the earlier generation, France
you just mentioned, most of the GDP was coming
out of state-owned companies for a very long
time.
And to the amazement of the world and, even
more so to the amazement of the French, they
were growing even a little bit faster than
the Germans, which is not the way the world
was supposed to be ordered.
The Italians had something somewhat similar;
the Spanish to a slight extent.
And these state-owned enterprises did rather
well.
They were market-competitive where there was,
you know, not talking about railways, but
all in all they did very well and they were
the main instruments of post-war modernization.
And you went over across to Japan, where they
did something very similar without owning
them.
I mean, who owned Mitsubishi during the great
growth phase is a reasonably interesting question.
It certainly was not the government, it was
not outside.
I think Mitsubishi owned Mitsubishi, and it
raised all kinds of-but it was a different
form of economic organization and state power
and state intervention in markets did an awful
lot to propel Japanese growth during the high-growth
period.
HAASS: So your question?
Q: My question is, is this latest generation,
which China is the leading candidate, comes
a lot out of Japan as well as the ownership,
is this going to go in the ways these others
did, which led to stable democracies in a
very great way when the odds weren't altogether
there?
Or is this simply another instrument of, you
know, increasingly totalitarian, authoritarian
government?
HAASS: What do you think?
KURLANTZICK: Well, that's a lot of questions
there.
But I think that the world is-I agree with
the premise initially, but the world is different
in many ways.
It's harder for a lot of these state capitalists
to protect their economies in some of the
same ways because they're already signatory
to a whole range of trade agreements that
bind them and make them so that many of their
state enterprises can't be protected in that
way.
I think that the question of whether China
is going to evolve, some of the countries
I had mentioned already are relatively democratic.
Whether China is going to evolve, I am not
an optimist that this is going to evolve into
a democratic system anytime soon.
I think people have gone broke betting that
it's going to change dramatically anytime
soon.
I do think that there was a role for the state
in those economies, and some of the ones that
I mentioned the state has played an important
developmental role.
Many of the states have now reached a certain
GDP level where the hand of the state is not
necessarily that effective.
HAASS: What about when it comes to innovation?
You know, a lot of it comes out of this country
and we're not an example of state capitalism
for the most part.
Is there a disconnect or a lack of correlation
between state capitalism and innovation?
KURLANTZICK: Overall, yes.
I think that some of the most effective state
capitalists, like Singapore and Norway and
others, have tried to use small portions of
state funds to set up certain incubators,
use state funds to promote industries that
are going to be important in the future.
China has done that as well, somewhat.
But overall, they lack deep venture capital
sectors, venture capitalists are afraid of
the government, and there is a problematic
correlation between state capitalism and indigenous
innovation.
HAASS: OK.
We've got time for one or two more.
Sure.
Q: Joshua, is there a correlation between
the underground economy, informal economy,
whatever you want to call it, and state capitalism?
Or is that just some overlap and some not?
KURLANTZICK: From my research, I think that
the correlation has more to do with poverty
and the rule of law.
So the underground economy in Singapore, I
don't actually know about Norway, but I would
be very surprised if Norway has a large underground
economy, it is very small.
Whereas in Russia and Malaysia, the two largest
sources of illicit capital flight in the world,
but at the same time, some of the others in
the top 10 of illicit capital flight are not
state economies, they're simply very poor
countries or countries with a very weak rule
of law.
HAASS: I saw hands.
Yes, sir?
Q: My best friend who cares about ethics recommended
your book.
My question is, does ethics play an important
role between the free market concept and state
capitalism?
HAASS: Anytime someone recommends your book
you don't want to disagree with the premise
of the question.
(Laughter.)
KURLANTZICK: Yeah.
I think that it's-I'm not an ethicist.
I think that the free market capitalism and
state capitalism are ideas that can be infused
and used in the most effective way possible.
In the book at the end I talk about ways to,
if countries are going to employ state capitalism,
to do so with effective governance in ways
in which the state doesn't predate (sp) on
citizens.
I don't think there's anything more or less
ethical about either of them, but in either
they can be conformed to ways that are more
beneficial to all.
HAASS: Listening to you talk about your book,
I get the sense that you're not so much saying
this is necessarily good or bad, it just depends
upon the specific variation of certain tendencies,
but it's actually a more nuanced sort of argument.
Is that fair?
KURLANTZICK: Yeah.
I mean, besides the democracy element, I wanted
to write the book because I saw the previous
literature on state capitalism as very one
way or the other.
And I didn't think that was necessarily accurate.
And I thought that looking at it from a policy
perspective, that looking at with such a broad-brush
approach is problematic, especially since
there are so many actors making policy decisions
involved, and that it was more nuanced than
had been presented in the past.
HAASS: With that, nuance is always a good
place to stop.
There are copies of the book.
Did I mention that?
There are copies of the book for sale.
Look, what you've heard here tonight, I think,
is a really, I used the word nuance, a really
thoughtful exposition.
Josh, I think, is a twofer.
He's regional expert, but he's also, with
this book and his previous book, been someone
who's producing books that are really idea
books.
And the previous one on the state of democracy,
this, in some ways, on the state of economies
and what are the intellectual directions they
are moving in, and I think he's putting together
a really important series of books and of
intellectual work.
So I commend anyone here or anyone watching
it to it.
I really think that, you know, this series
is an important contribution to the field
and to the literature.
So I want to again congratulate him on what
he's done and urge him to keep doing it.
KURLANTZICK: OK, thank you.
(Applause.)
HAASS: There's a reception in the back.
And if I didn't mention it, there's books
in the back.
(Laughter.)
(END)